hasta su fin natural.
Así que al considerar la muerte como parte
del tejido cultural y social de la vida,
las decisiones diarias de la gente sobre su salud
y su cuidado se ven afectadas.
El patriarca del clan maternal de mi esposo,
Nenet Katcha,
está llegando a los 100 años de edad, por lo que podemos sabemos.
Y hay signos crecientes
de que está próximo a partir hacia su propio viaje a Puya.
Y su muerte se lamentará enormemente,
pero sé que la familia de mi esposo
espera con ilusión el momento
en el que puedan manifestar de forma ritual
lo que su notable presencia ha significado en sus vidas,
y puedan contar ritualmente
la narración de su vida,
tejiendo su historia
en la historia de su comunidad.
La historia de él es la historia de ellos.
Sus cantos fúnebres les cantarán una canción sobre ellos mismos.
Y es una historia que no tiene un inicio discernible,
ni un final previsible.
Es una historia que continúa
hasta mucho después de que el cuerpo ya no continúe.
La gente me pregunta si siento temor o repulsión
por participar en una cultura
donde las manifestaciones físicas de la muerte
nos saludan a cada paso.
Pero veo algo profundamente transformador
en experimentar la muerte como un proceso social
y no sólo como uno biológico.
En realidad, la relación entre la vida y la muerte
tiene su propio drama en el sistema de salud de Estados Unidos,
donde las decisiones sobre cuánto estirar
el hilo de la vida están basadas en nuestros vínculos emocionales
y sociales con la gente que nos rodea,
no sólo en la habilidad de la medicina en prolongar la vida.
Nosotros, como los torajanos,
basamos nuestras decisiones sobre la vida
en los significados y definiciones
que le atribuimos a la muerte.
No estoy sugiriendo que todos en la audiencia
deban correr y adoptar las tradiciones
de los torajanos.
Podría ser un poco difícil
hacerlo en los Estados Unidos.
Pero quiero plantear qué podemos ganar
al ver la muerte física no sólo como un proceso biológico
sino como parte de la gran historia humana.
¿Cómo sería mirar
a la forma humana fallecida con amor
porque es una parte íntima de lo que todos somos?
Si pudiésemos expandir nuestra definición de la muerte
para abarcar la vida,
podríamos experimentar la muerte como una parte de la vida
y quizás enfrentar a la muerte
con algo distinto al miedo.
Quizás una de las respuestas a los desafíos
que enfrentamos en el sistema de salud de Estados Unidos,
especialmente con respecto a los cuidados del fin de la vida,
sea tan simple como un cambio de perspectiva,
y el cambio de perspectiva en este caso
sería mirar la vida social de cada muerte.
Nos ayudaría a reconocer que la forma en que limitamos
nuestras conversaciones sobre la muerte
como algo que es médico o biológico
es una reflejo de una cultura más amplia que todos compartimos,
la de evadir la muerte, teniendo miedo de hablar sobre ella.
Si pudiésemos considerar y valorar
otras clases de conocimiento sobre la vida,
incluyendo otras definiciones de la muerte,
tendríamos el potencial de cambiar las discusiones
que tenemos sobre el fin de la vida.
Podría cambiar la forma en que morimos,
pero más importante,
podría transformar la forma en que vivimos.
(Aplausos)